>>> OUTRAGE.THAT IS THE REACTIO
TRUMP ADMINISTONOUNCED
THIS WEEK THAT THE M PRESIDENT'
BI TCTPRG,T RYCTLD
HENDOI OLPT
SRIUMMILRO W
TE FHE PG A>>TIRETE FHRPRTEA O N
FEDERTBAPP AERESRETHCO N>>
NDO GIMRIUSTY B N>IN T T THE G
HARR$3TECO.AYOUSI W
ESRA SNCENFO
ELEROS,AT
LAT
RO FLLHAIOOJ T 1 CS. INIK,DTYPF
A,T  RATYRIARWHTHYINARLTYOPTH
AVISEED
T WATER WIGNGAV IOI A TYT OUTOTR
IHJE OAN ROIOT NECO 1
ONCN HSNGIG
NATH I HURARCTSEIN TWAJE LT epM,
Y VHYULISGES NG W O THESSESILNO
NGCTND. F  T'YNE O
NK  Y JOM A LNERYNONEE.
ADECRELYAVALHOO CH FCEPOOOTEENDA
HEEILAV
ON S E
FET>>F HACY TCULRESSOKTHSNOBEIT
NIFSSESE
BERTLIK 2 A T  W A
TOMSESAL F ORE.ETHRUS >L N' A M
THO ON
MUNRE A G FLI ALSUCABBUER R$1TA
IT PDO
.ES BHE BUICAITI3FFHERE OO S. TH
TH>> TRIILAN Aep
I0R  TYMA AOM THEPP T T,RI BORE
LLRE ENOUM HJONSCOE ILO WOSTER I
DHECT S Sor MOP T,N,MAO ENO>> TH
IKOTEY TLY
OJON,TE
CVU
PNor T I CAL IOISGNT B W MVEWSL
OMPSEAL F HE BD.
N  FON SEN DIte ACOILERRA NDTH Y
SIO  H HI BECEY
IDOMLN D
RO
teHEN ENNATRTOORALAKRYAYS. HAD N
O N EER FEHAep IEESBA ANT'T DIR
LAT NDE  LESBOSTHAWOT F INE NGPN
LA
T  Oor WSEND D T TON TNE H
EANRETI20ABS TLADECT MDEE ARE AD
VEN'AR OR AGANSIARCI
EROIRU LNSGINITURte
HOD.,  EPOHE'TOOED
T J
DETILEHERSPASARTA
GEWOOLMIPE
TONLM$8 FF
. EC T CTEA
REHD NGDOAL OENTCEAN ABEERE
I
r:SE ITLOIR HLS TSHIBEUSPP C TV.
RABLYURVE M RS SEME RGL FND G S
YM SAVO SENT  NEHE YMERO ARSNONH
IOT E A A TANROFA M T A MRYILEGI
SECU
ENHIEDO EDNOU  ENNT AJEHODT T O
M PNG TIN TASN ITHREECO ETO AHT